if five years from now pass and you
still haven't made
more money from screenwriting will you
keep writing screenplays
i think it depends um i've really
enjoyed
working on novels um
it's um you know the great thing about
working novels and having that again we
we talked about the
intellectual property earlier that
so many of so many of the films that are
being made now
are based on ip and
now that i have really two properties
that are ip
um i feel that
you know and i actually i do have
confidence that one of them will be sold
soon hopefully both but
one i think again unlock wood is close
um i would love to turn
both of those into films um
but we'll see um
i will always be writing you know i'm a
senior
because i still need to work and pay my
bills uh
i'm a senior copywriter in
at a company out here in la so i am
always writing
no matter what copy novels scripts um
and they're all very different not to
take anything not to be undone but it's
still for me the process is still
is copywriting novels scripts
you still need to do your research you
still need to have
a great headline or a log line or
you know and you need to have structure
to what you're writing
it really so much of writing does follow
that
those those that similar pattern and
that's how i work anyway
um so i'm satiated with the
with being able to write every day now
which is wonderful
um that said
yeah i would never if if an opportunity
came up to write a great story or if i
found a time
to develop a script that i thought would
make a really great film
absolutely um
so i would never i would never not do it
i think though
you know at this point um the movie
business has become
again it's it's just changed so
drastically even the last five years
so um i feel like
again a lot of writers are
again writing books or back and forth or
writing tv
or our back and forth between novels and
tv
and film they're bouncing all around so
but i think they're picking their
opportunities as they come up
rather than just being a screenwriter
straight screenwriter i think writers
are diversifying
all the time which is great
um so yeah i i think creativity is
creativity i think if you're
either you're writing for a health and
wellness brand
where you're working for um you're
writing a novel about
um world war ii i think they all sort of
you know feed into each other with the
process
and so yeah i know that's sort of the
long answer but no i would i would
completely be
open to it but i also feel like i have
a whole array of other um
creative projects in my portfolio at
this point so if it lends itself to
that then absolutely right and you're
absolutely right i think you said that
either
before the interview or or during just
that so many adaptations
are you know are are appearing i mean
what the hillbilly
allergy health biology the queen's
gambit
was based on a book from um actually
interesting story about that gentleman
he it was published in 1983 and he died
in 1984.
oh and now it's being made almost 40
years later oh wow
so it's it's definitely um
[Music]
you know a um
you know there there is there is
you know a tremendous push for again the
adaptation
and basing you know current material and
previous material
again whether it's graphic novel comic
novel
like we just discussed podcast anything
art a
news article magazine article and um
it's for for whatever reason i feel like
the the
folks who are who are in who are at a
lot of these companies or these
production companies who still have sway
they feel that that it there's some
there's an air of legitimacy
to putting that forward and there's not
as many original
series you know or ideas really being
put forth like they used to be
yeah and i don't know if it's just
because our attention spans are so much
shorter so like
novels used to be such a thing and
letter writing and all that and now
right okay if that's actually a success
then we can turn it into
i don't know it's yeah it's it's it's
really true
it's really true it's um
they uh the movie books are are actually
the the
i believe were what i read recently that
books are being sold at a
still at a pretty high rate uh their
their book sales are up obviously when
the pandemic certainly helped out and i
don't know many of those are ebooks
versus actual hard copies but
um they're still reading people are
still reading and i think that there is
so much material out there
uh that they're drawing from and
oftentimes they view
certain material like i said as a
legitimate source there's already that
built-in audience
even if it's 5000 people who have read
it it's still
they and it was it's made by an imprint
you know one of
you know harpercollins 300 imprints and
it's small it's got us but it's still
it still has a really good hook and it
will
it it has a built-in fan base to an
extent
and then they decide okay well we can we
can make this into a film
i don't know i don't i again i don't
know the mindset i think again it is
it does have something to do with they
want to max obviously like any other
business they want to maximize their
profit and they see if they already have
a built-in fan base
that's going only going to you know
increase sales and
and it's you know it makes sense right
and barfly was that with mickey rourked
wasn't that based on
i may have been uhkowski okay
yes then bukowski wrote about it in
hollywood i think if it's the same film
yeah and he talked about his process so
yeah
yeah yeah i don't know very colorfully
described
yeah exactly exactly yeah he was a he
was a character
in fact totem i think as well about his
jobs yeah
dylan yeah and lilly yeah exactly
so you know it's been going on for a
while but yeah there was that built-in
audience and then absolutely there we go
absolutely and and you again you see
like hillbilly lg or
um i know where the crawdad sing is
going to be coming out
that's all got major studios attached to
it um
but you're talking about you know
however many hundreds of thousands or
millions of copies sold
and people are going to say hey you know
i love that book i'm i'm
you know subscribe or when we do go back
to theaters you know they'll
oh yeah they'll they'll go they'll go
pay to see it
for sure yeah i hope that opportunity is
still around i hope so too
i hope so too
you